John Ambrose is like kind of the male
version of large ain't like they are
super-duper-duper compatible okay and so
he really really it's like a true charm
battle for sure and I love it
my boyfriend he's coming we are here on
the seat wow what an exciting day night
I know it is what time is it the middle
of the night right now powering through
bring it together where does this equal
pick up take us through what's happening
so the sequel picks up like no time has
passed okay like pretty much no time has
passed from the first movie did this to
the sequel a large Union Peter um are in
a really good place they're having a
great time it's an awesome relationship
and then the movie is a little bit more
mature in the sense that like all of a
sudden things aren't perfect anymore and
so like kind of actually dealing with
real-life relationship problems and then
we have our new character John Ambrose
comes in and kind of shakes it up and
mr. Fisher mr. Jordan Fisher who we all
love so much and the whole movie is kind
of like two movies in one kynos we have
the Pierre and Lara Jean story but then
we also have the large gene and the John
Ambrose story and it kind of is I don't
know it's a more fully flushed like
mature movie which I really really like
yeah yeah so we're just kind of you know
do you have doing the same and and and
making it better which is great I'm
having more more boys we're boys funny
you say that because Noah actually told
us that after you guys cut him and
Jordan will continue pretending to fight
over you and he said you quote love it I
love it I love it I really really liked
it how is Lana handling all of this
guys Oh fighting over her we'll still
being like character a little bit yeah
and like fight over ha ha Joe love it
you were living every girl's dream oh
yeah and they know I love it too it's
great yeah but they do fight they do
fight like play fight yeah which is
really sweet and I think the two of them
are really good friends as well so it's
really made like the I think it's hard
having like you know when new actors
come in it's like when your cast is
already so tight it can be a like a
tricky situation but Jordan has like
integrations also well and like him and
know are great friends and they love
hanging out and so it's been that I have
also added such a positive layer to the
movie I love that are you okay mm-hmm
you know who I am
Johnny impressed McLaren knowing that
the first one was such a massive hit is
there any pressure that you're feeling
with this one I mean I believe so much
in like the cast and the crew and the
filmmakers so I I know are gonna do a
great job but there is a little bit of
like a man I just flick I want it to be
even better sure I'm not sure but the
pressure and the fans like we have such
a loving fan base that I think I think
they're gonna be really happy so it
would be unrealistic for me to say that
there is no pressure but like I also
very I really believe what we're doing
and I'm I'm proud of it so I promise I
am NOT
going to break your heart I promise not
to wake you
I feel like Peter convinced me was such
a teen dream in the first one does that
hold up in the second one is he is
dreaming yes oh of course
I mean I really would it would be
impossible for Peter who would see to
not be dreamy I think in this movie
Peter Kavinsky is still very very dreamy
and he's still he's still super ideal
for like all Oh everyone but I think in
this movie we kind of he's more he's
flawed in this movie and he is more of
like a real person because not no one
can be perfect
sure sure and I think this movie it
should just shines a light into peers
just a normal person and he has flaws he
makes mistakes as well which I think
Noah has loved you know doing that
because it makes me more real character
I'm really relatable so but he's still
as dreamy as the first I'm gonna need
that letter back where does that Johnny
Ambrose stack up then with that you know
it's funny it's like
I have always thought that large enough
here were so perfect together and then
what Jordan Fisher brings to the table
when he plays John Ambrose it like there
are moments major moments in the past
month where I'm like oh whoa like Jordan
makes a really valid valid go at maybe
large and should be with him really it's
very convincing and and and John Ambrose
is so charming and John Ambrose is like
kind of the male version of Largey like
they are super duper duper compatible
and so he really really it's like a true
charm battle for sure and I love it and
you're literally in the middle of this
love triangle and I've got to feel so
perfect you did tell et about this scene
that you really wanted to be in the
movie
Jordan confirmed it that you wanted to
do the nursing home scene and then you
wanted to kiss in the snow oh yeah how
was that scene for you came true
it did wait I did say that didn't I the
one thing I was like I didn't even told
you guys yeah it's really beautiful I've
never worked in the snow I don't think
and so that was my first time like just
it felt like a dream right
it felt it's a fairytale and I think
that's part of like Johnny Ambrose
provides like Largey lives in her head
and she loves fantasy and and there's so
many moments in this movie where she
gets that with Johnny Ambrose and so
kissing in the snow which is by the ways
it's just like soap it suds that it is
yeah so what they do is they put it in
like a leaf blower and it's just
literally just soap so it's not as
magical as I would think that it would
be in real yeah didn't really care about
everyone any hazing going on for Jordan
he said no did we haze because we have
some other we have lacrosse Butler's
well I heard about the hair and makeup
room when you guys doing these like
dances in there and you were like oh
yeah about that I don't know I haven't
haze maybe I should have well cuz I did
all the guys kind of against you are
they pulling any pranks on you anything
like that
now now I'm realizing like yeah good I
actually I'm gonna say I'm in love with
you Archie only I feel like Noah became
sort of the Internet's boyfriend if you
will what is the weirdest question or
funniest question that you've gotten
about him I think maybe like that we
were gonna get married or we are married
Oh people thought you guys were married
at mate yes I think I heard a rumor like
that is that weird for you to hear those
types of I'm like am I like I don't know
are we very can we be married um no I
think that's probably the weirdest thing
either
I guess people o people ask me like what
he smells like what do you say it's good
like it smells good but I get I'll get
like girls will come up to me and want
to know what it's like what he smells
like if he's really that tall in real
life which he is which he is that type
of thing what is the weirdest fan
reaction that you've gotten it wasn't
weird it was really it was just really
sweet I was going I was getting my nails
done and I looked really bad I had with
like I just looked really bad and I get
my nails done and I was like keeping to
myself and I finished and I walked up to
pay and the girl who was checking me out
goes like
like really quiet and I go yeah and all
of a sudden every single technician
every single technician in the whole
entire salon jumped up and they're like
like freaking out and but it was so
quiet so I think what they have been
doing is they I've been texting each
other like throughout the whole entire
session and then when I confirmed it
they just like got up and like freaked
out and was there all screaming I would
like have any that was I think the most
like intense
[Music]